[Music]
ladies and gentlemen ination for
departure please check to see that your
seat belts are securely fastened your
window shades are open seat backs are in
the upright and lock position VOR Nation
thank you so much for listening to the
plane project I just want to give a huge
shout out to sity if the uh Wi-Fi was
not broken on my flight from Sweden to
New York it would have never happened
kind of uh just got my work done sat
somehow got ridiculously inspired please
bear with me with the quality of the
audio obviously I was in the air and in
that zone I hope you enjoy this kind of
like almost like a rant album I'm very
proud of it I have a funny feeling a lot
of you get tremendous value out of it
and I would love to know which one was
your favorite rant enjoy this enjoy this
enjoy this see
you hunger there's nothing better how
hungry are you how much do you really
want it be proud of your hunger do not
suppress your ambition it is a good
thing build the biggest thing you can
build do not tear down other people's
projects but do not be embarrassed of
wanting to build the biggest project of
them all do not suppress your hunger do
not allow anybody to tell you it is
wrong do not let anybody tell you that
you're dreaming too big too high have
practicality in it deploy patience in it
understand The Audacity Of It protect
your ambition it is absolutely
fundamentally one of your secret sauces
but please do not let ambition cloak and
trick you into thinking you can do the
wrong things your ambition does not need
to be fulfilled at the expense of others
in fact when harnessed properly your
ambition should Inspire and help so many
please think about your legacy and your
teens and your 20s and your 30s and your
40s and please if you are in your 50s
and 60s understand the circumstances of
Technology have created a format for you
to exploit and enjoy that it is not too
late for you to rekindle your
diminishing ambition that your phone and
the distributions of the modern day
platforms named YouTube and Instagram
and Linkedin and podcast
create an opportunity for the next three
decades of your life to harness your
ding ambition please please harness your
ambition and mold it into the incredible
thing that it can be the driving force
to the happiness of your
life parents please let them win on
their terms not yours your children are
not a direct indication of who you are
they're a byproduct there's proxies
there's things but so many of you are
deploying your insecurities about
yourself on your children because you
genuinely care about what people around
you are saying about them other families
other friends other relatives talking
about your kids you value their povs
more than listening to your own children
it's not necessarily the words it's
their actions it is your job as a leader
of a family to reverse engineer the
players in the game and put them in the
best position to succeed and the thought
that so many of you are parenting your
children predicate on your short-term
fulfillment of other people's opinions
devastates the out of me and one
day we'll devastate you too and probably
devastates you right now and so if that
line hit you directly in your
heart or your brain please do something
about it I may never make a video more
important to me than this I'm the
byproduct of the most incredible
parents who disproportionally put me in
a position to succeed because they were
confident in who they were and did not
allow other people to judge them and
allowed me to live in happiness and be
who I was so please parents please
understand that your concern of being
judged by artificial truths is
positioning your children not to fulfill
the happiness that you have to want for
them it also creates an unbelievable
weakness for them not to be able to deal
I able to deal because my mother and
father put me into a framework that
allowed me to fail and allowed me to be
me please don't let your insecurities be
imposed and please don't hide them under
the false statements that you're trying
to do what's right for them what's right
for them is to give them freedom to be
themselves as long it is noble and fair
do not judge their creativity or the
angles they see that you do not see now
please High L Left Right opposite
directions pull from them find your
balance in your extremes hold those
opposite feelings and try to make
diamonds out of the friction and I
believe so many of you you are so
different professionally than you are in
your regular life in that context please
start trying to understand the things
that make you pick in your extreme
differences that you pull from other
directions because in there is the Magic
in there is the happiness for the rest
of your life try to reconcile and create
Frameworks and conversations and debates
with yourself to how you can pull in
different directions have different
aspects of your game be different in
different scenarios and reconcile them
and make them
a clean complex understanding concoction
find your balance in your left and right
your dark and light you're open and
closed you're aggressive and passive
find your balance and communicate
it everybody's got something everybody's
sitting right now as they're watching
this video and theyve got something that
they're dwelling about something that's
pulling them down something that's going
them back something that's happened a
long time ago or something that's going
on right now everybody's got
and I just want people to know that if
we could just all play a little more Ely
and realize that it just makes it a
little bit easier for you to deal with
your once you realize that you stop
worrying about everybody else you know
why you stop worrying about everybody
else because a you realize they've done
something and B you don't give a
about their opinion cuz they've got
something they come in different shapes
and sizes but to that person
it's theirs and so please my friends
please understand what everybody's got
their pain now it's an even
playing field deploy empathy and deploy
confidence in yourself cuz nobody's
judgment on you means they've got
something
too it doesn't matter 99% of things
don't matter how do you allow yourself
to look at the small things like
somebody has a nicer car or somebody has
more followers on Instagram doesn't
matter if your sister's winning or
losing it doesn't matter if your best
friend's making $100,000 a year and you
haven't figured out who you are it
doesn't matter my friends the only thing
that matters is how you judge yourself
inside your head and do you understand
where you're going and how you're going
to do it and how long you have to get
there do not be crippled by the
short-term narrative based on things
that do not matter because all the
things that are being thrown at you on a
daily basis that make you judge yourself
in the short term don't matter all those
artificial doubts that were poured into
your brain by your inner circle and your
outer game don't matter matter please
watch this video every day anytime
something sucks like remember it
doesn't matter in the macro they're only
so few things that you will think about
on your deathbed so understand whatever
you're upset about right now
fundamentally doesn't matter it just
doesn't in the end what matters is did
you do it your way did you die on your
sword did you do it on your feet did you
listen to yourself and did you do it the
right
way please stop judging judgment is
flying from every Dimension
every angle everybody's judging and I'm
just ask me please to stop the are
you the do you think you are I just
am flabbergasted by people's inability
to realize the hypocrisy of the
judgments you can judge in your mind let
it Fester let it articulate be
thoughtful don't be quick to judge look
at yourself first just because you may
not be doing a you might be doing C Is
there a difference if you were in a
mindset where judging and dragging
somebody else down contributes to your
happiness you fundamentally
monst this me and I implore you that
maybe this second starts the process of
going in the other direction offense
always beats defense in this new world
of communication where everybody has the
power to share the Judgment of others is
that an all-time high in its
distribution but my friends this has
been the way it's always been for the
get nothing has changed it's time that
we look at each other and understand
what we really are are and deal with the
harsh harsh TRS of some of our
shortcomings and Judgment of others is
at the Tipp and top I will not judge you
you're you I will talk about my truths I
will debate you who the am I I'm
zero I'm nobody I will not judge you you
do you do it the way that will build for
your legacy allow it to be in a way that
when everybody judges that those 8
billion people judge you correctly the
way you wish they would the way that
would make your grandkids proud but I
was zero my moment's judging zero and I
implore you to do the
[Music]
same I need nothing and you need to
learn how to figure that out too when
your expectation of others is zero when
you do not rely on a single person
emotionally or financially when you
create a game a world where you no
longer put the responsibility on your
parents or older brother your Mentor
Society a country a flag a race a Creed
when you take on full mother
responsibility for yourself in yourself
you require nothing of anybody else when
you become that accountable when you
understand that it is on you truly and
nobody owes you anything it gets really
really quiet and then you can start
really achieving something because when
you aren't at the mercy of
others
you it's never ever been more practical
than right this second to be somebody
that gives because of the way
communication is now structured in our
society that the ability for everybody
to distribute it is in play and that the
truth and Karma has never been more
practical and Powerful please my friends
step up and start doing more good behind
the scenes stuff that people don't see
give give give and then if you need to
ask understand that the key to the gift
give give strategy is zero expectations
so many of you are giving with the
thought of what you're going to get in
return and my friends that is not giving
that is manipulating the outcome in the
midterm giving has never been more
practical and never been more powerful
because the depths of how it can be
reached and passed on and the stories
being told be on that team please give
if you can something more
daily
Always
Forever I want you to understand this
project I want you to understand it I am
driven by guilt and gratitude I'm driven
by them because I'm so thankful and I
feel so honestly guilty to my parents
and my circumstance I thank everybody
for all those losses I took along the
way from the kids that made me drink
piss out of a Pepsi can cuz I couldn't
speak English in do New Jersey I thank
you Dover I thank the school system for
creating a game that does not allow the
ambitious and creative and the people
that see it to suc suceed in the short
term I thank the friends and family who
whispered behind my back who casted A
Narrative of My Success because I was
losing in the framework of the 80s and
90s where college and school was the
only variable of an indicator of your
success I thank them and most of all I
thank my mother and father and my sister
and brother who lived in the Cocoon that
I lived in for the first 18 years of my
life that was limited in its vacation
time escapism that was limited in its
abundance that would have become the
weapons of my shortcomings I thank I
thank them all and I'm driven by
gratitude and guilt as I create this
project and I want my audience to
understand that I spit flames
and bars for the rest of my life out of
guilt and gratitude cuz I wanted so
bad for you I feel your pains
and shortcomings I feel them I see them
I read them I sense them I can taste
them and what I want for you is what I
have emotionally so I come to you and
deliver you the project on the plan as a
collective rant that I hope inspires the
switch from defense to offense that
becomes the fuel to your happiness and I
remind all of you all your shortcomings
and losses and negativity is yesterday
it is all fundamentally behind you even
the worst of it and it is up to you to
step forward and start positive offense
as your new truth and I beg that for you
and I hope this project
suffocated it and inspired it and
created it and enabled it and I love
[Music]
you